[Applaudissements]
etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait et ce à peine dix ans ça fait
dix ans que je fais cette émission j'ai
déjà vu un costume aussi pourri pour
halloween
j'ai jamais un costume aussi éclaté sans
rigoler c'est incroyable mon soir à tous
et bienvenue à tout bas
merci d'être là les cherry on va vous
changer les idées ce soir comme tous les
soirs on va essayer de rigoler de
débattre on a bien sûr parlé du
professeur à ou parce que rare on est
toujours important ah bah oui bah oui
bah oui bah oui c'est important et ce
soir et se sont tous déguisés pour
l'occasion puisque c'était c'est quoi
ces c'est halloween
quant à l'appareil il y aura jean marie
bigard et sa femme lola qui seront avec
nous et on a préparé des trucs de ouf
bien sûr comme d'habitude à on appelait
j'ai des chroniqueurs pour halloween
et comme d'habitude il y en a pour qui
ça a marché est là pour qui ça va bien
marcher
bon en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on va rigoler ils sont avec nous ce
soir je vous demande d'applaudir celui
qui est là c'est jean michel maire on va
voir tout de suite son costume en quoi
il est déguisé jean michel mr débat
[Applaudissements]
faudra t il
nous équipes de trucs mais moi je m'en
allais converser conneries je m'en bats
les couilles alors ils auront débattu et
ça va hyper bien ce que je vois de
pastis de mon bistrot non mike weir
trouve une photo de moi jen ne boira du
parti situe dans le milieu
alors on va voir emploi et je remets ma
vie dans un instant et pour le moment
pajama castaldi et laon quoi il dit
[Applaudissements]
mais alors je vais vous dire retournez
vous êtes encore momie sur mobile
ordonnance au qu'on va voir mammy mammy
mammy mammy c'est ça certes gallois
sartec lapointe yann perreau a vraiment
bravo à toi à moi vous allez en avoir
tout de suite emploi et déguisés
justement après momie c'est ma belle
mort
[Applaudissements]
là
s'il a du chien
donc je vais ta peau à l'église et le
déguisement est magnifique non m vous
êtes magnifique i sa chaussure mais
92,20 pas mal non
vous êtes magnifique ça vous va hyper
bien bravo isabelle et la mort voilà des
101 dalmatiens oui mais échoue elle sans
rigoler vouer
mais ça ça vous va bien en fait des
voyages
oui mais non non mais je me demande s'il
faut pas faire un délires capillaires un
peu comme ça laissait un peu poussé non
mais je vous trouvez pas dans le public
c'est pas mal franchement c'est long
surtout qu'il fait aussi qu'ils allaient
sortir l'ue de 20 ont plus au chaud j'ai
l'impression que vous allez faire une
bonne émission
allez c'est parti on accueille rêvons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
et
[Applaudissements]
je lourde et tu sais toi aussi tu sûr
que je devrais pas les déchets en train
de me rendre compte que vous êtes
normalement
jan michiel hessels a dit pères
verrouille l'écurie on accueille tout de
suite
allez on va accueillir on va cueillir
gilbert d'être paisible
[Applaudissements]
l'un d'entre eux qui est acquis mais dès
qu'on galère tu vas tu c'est une marque
à 7 ce qui est plus du tout à l'égout
bédard car je suis devenu sympathique
mais vous faites toujours autant flipper
merci attention on va accueillir tout de
suite
kelly b novelli
[Applaudissements]
et
[Rires]
alors très sympa la tenue très sympa
mais vous êtes en quoi non je suis en
sorcière déguisés en clowns d'accord ah
au fait que c'est vous qui avez créé un
format à coup c'est un petit peu je
ferais bien c'est pas mal
je voudrais vraiment qu'à chaque fois on
passe un plan sur les deux personnes n'a
pas vraiment c est normal soit
exceptionnel allez on va accueillir tout
de suite on m'a accueilli la petite
famille est avec oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis daenerys targaryen la guerrière
vous connaissez pas ce que vous êtres et
aidera dès les séries aux causes bichot
vous allez c'est parti
non non pas des couilles à saillé
comment ça qui fait tiffany mais est ce
vraiment vous allez faire raymond toutes
les missions rené peut-être au tir
honeywell
allez on accueille tout de suite
en fait c'est plus du tout qui à la
mairie et je ne sais pas lundi bien sûr
je sais qui a roulé là-bas mais juge
bernard là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
flo
[Applaudissements]
c'est dracula apparemment c'est dracula
il suspecte du sang
[Applaudissements]
je suis là comte dracula saiema et vue
ouais ben je verrais ça vous va hyper
bien et tout vous va vous aimez moi je
suis un top model puis il est devenu
complètement ça voilà je sus qui est
entendue après sa mort est bon ce soir
demain bernard montiel que la policia
nature est enfin à votre avis en quoi
raymond et déguisés chez vous en quoi
mes relais grenet s'est toujours donné
honeywell oui c'est vrai jean-michel non
non mais non ils s'en iront par jour que
tu as une heure
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est d'abord et orale mais y'a
pas là vous n'êtes pas là par bats les
couilles
[Applaudissements]
décidé je vais décider de tout étudiant
vite c'est trop longue et je me suis
laissée dans les contrôles de poitrine
des femmes
[Applaudissements]
il est fou de moi lui tout le monde veut
vous et nos invités ce soir douze mois
jeu aussi ils sont déguisés jean marie
bigard et lola marois
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
les deux